alors on parle des miss et c'est vrai
qu'en ce moment il ya aussi à beaucoup
de polémiques c'est la première année où
il y autant de polémiques sur l'argent
sur la maintenance ont tous prêté sur le
jury sur est-ce qu'il faut continuer
l'élection ou pas on commence à
moyennement parler ça fait penser un peu
aux [ __ ] ou avant personne n'avait
le roi du toucher maintenant l'émission
commence un peu à balancer alors
malédiction catherine pourquoi est ce
que pour vous c'est une malédiction
devenir miss france je pense une
malédiction parce qu'après on voit
qu'elles ont du mal à vous êtes et des
contre exemples mais qu'elles ont du mal
à prêt à rebondir c'est à dire que quand
on est jugé sur son physique c'est
compliqué de se vendre après pour autre
chose là qu'on peut pas prétendre
vouloir être jugé intellectuellement
quand on sait sciemment vendu que sur le
fait que vous n'êtes pas connu ce
problème catherine forte imagination
juste avant de faire parler les autres
effectivement d'abord est ce que c'est
vrai tout ce qu'on dit en ce moment
notamment le concours j'ai lu ça on
s'arrange pour qu'elle soit affamé juste
avant le concours pour qu'elle soit très
fines donc tout ce qu'on veut plus
aujourd'hui parce que les jeunes filles
qui nous regardent attention anorexie
est ce que c'est vrai qu'on vous avez
affamés ou pas ou non vous c'était
l'époque j'ai de fontenay bah oui parce
que nous c'était plutôt inverse c'est à
dire car non on n'a fait que manger mais
oui avec jean paul a été tellement
content d'être invité à traquer les
bonnes tables cavale avant l'élection
même à son vous n'hésitez pas tu ne
manges rien c'est que des produits dick
fuld bien ce nom dans la préparation
pendant notre préparation
pas de régime pas du tout mais après
c'était une autre époque dévier sa civic
alliés du coup qu'elle générait beaucoup
de journées des beaucoup de choses il
arrête c'est une patronne comme ça donc
ce qu'on dit maintenant c'est que si
vite il y aura tendance à leur dire deux
jours avant vous mangez feuille de
salade et buvez vous buvez la soupe aux
choux à toutes fins et pour être très
très belle ça m'étonnerait pas non plus
pas tous styles de sylvie tellier de
faire ça parce que moi tu vas tu évites
alliés mais vous faire une idée très
bien quand jean-pierre alors quand jean
pierre foucault a demandé à sylvie
tellier qu'est ce que vous allez paiera
de faire après je l'avais appelé avant
je vais dit tu vas dire qu'on va
travailler ensemble et décalé de sortie
de miss france on a fait je m'occupais
d'une petite chaîne de télé qui sape le
match tv on a fait de télévision pendant
un an
donc s'il est élu je la connais très
bien c'est tout sauf ça elle veut que
les gens soient bien dans leurs corps
c'est juste que avant et un concours à
l'ordre faites attention
la veille de l'élection sans négliger
m'ad'abord comptant un peu le cou à
certaines rumeurs notamment d'autres par
exemple on sait que la l'île maurice
elles s'étaient toutes trois étaient 30
pendant les trente ans vend sélectionné
12 mais l'ignorent ont les ont les
annoncera le samedi et les critères sur
lesquels elles vont être sélectionnés
mais elles ne le savent pas forcément
c'est quand on à l'île maurice
ponctualité évidemment esprit de
camaraderie c'est mieux en croches pas
la gueule de sa copine maîtrise de soi
photogénie évidemment manucure pédicure
hygiène impeccable allen impeccable il
faut également savoir faire un lit on
peut passer le comité peut passer dans
la chambre d'hôtel pour voir si la
chambre est impeccable s'est passé d'un
portable toute une journée être social
avec les camarades
est ce que tout ça c'était vrai à votre
époque c'est là dessus quand fête bat
sans le savoir vous avez été choisi
parmi les douze à moi personnellement
pas tout ça déjà téléphone portable à
mon époque y en avait pas sincèrement
pourquoi on sélectionne et douce parce
qu'après c'est un combat pendant un an
il faut cesser on est un peu comme un
représentant politique faut être là tous
les jours avec le sourire quoi qui nous
arrive consomme malade a fatigué ou pas
c'est tous les jours sur les routes
on nous a élus pour ça pour être
l'ambassadrice de la france gardait le
sourire être parfait sauf si vous saviez
que pendant le voyage à chaque fois
plans voyages gala 12 qui vont être
sélectionnés dont j mr permanence dès
qu'on vous pas dit et ponctué la tendre
et fragile va pas la mettre dans les
douze mois je me suis un camion n'est
pas que je fais que citer miss réunion
le jour de l'élection n'a même pas pu se
présenter elle était très faible
elle a eu un problème de santé on prend
pas le risque de la mettre dans les
gosses parce qu'après ces buts ont pas
voté mais c'est énorme et c'est normal
c'est tout à fait normaux nous aimons
croire ben pas encore il est de bon ton
aujourd'hui de vouloir dégommer tous
d'être dans le le légat later cela de
deux réseaux sociaux tout ça est tout à
fait normaux demande si c'est vrai parce
qu'ils aient beaucoup de choses autre
malédiction des miss comme ça on le sera
97 2% sondage insee de leurs mots
perdent leur mec l'année de l'élection
c'est quand même c'est quand même
hallucinant ça ça veut dire que
finalement face au syndrome un peu j'ai
à dire pardon aux femmes de footballeurs
mais le côté je suis pas connu chez avec
à moosch
alors pour dégager le ciel maintenant je
serai le québécois à vous l'avez fait
vous bah ouais le jour où tu es élu
après tu dis pas tu peux mais on est
heureux d'être ce qui touche à tout
amour c'est différent non merci on a dit
écoutez vous feriez exactement ça vous
étiez mister france qui est impossible
[Applaudissements]
mission puis vous étiez connu doyer et
mature ya ça tu peux tu découvert cette
attitude non mais c'est pour les petites
maladresses alors faut chasser pour les
aider les petits copains des candidates
quand ils voient que leur leur copine et
lui savent que casillas est mort moi
j'ai maintenant la voie pardon la chose
que sylvie m'a dit ouais gto qu'on était
en voiture jallère direction paris et
donc j'avais ma robe est tous dans la
voiture et la halle sur toi même dit à
un petit copain chtioui et baby dior non
mais c'est horrible vous rendez compte
il parce que saddam prédire que quand tu
deviens connu et jolie salle amour de
coup c'est pas ça c'est qu'en fait aussi
des petites amies ne supporte pas notre
changement de vitesse c'était horrible
mde et tu fais quoi tu avec keenan a et
c'était pénible quoi douter vous avez vu
les joueurs que tu es en ligue nationale
olic deux boxeuses bobonne qu'ils ont
rencontré côté des vingt ans quand tu
passes en ligue 1 que tu commences à
avoir des millions qui sont avec des top
models des migrants
alors j'aimerais d'abord un mot de
sébastien parce que toi sébastien tu as
beaucoup paparazzé j'imagine deux miss
bah oui en général quand il ya une miss
qui est élu on cherche à savoir avec
quelle est donc il ya souvent des petits
copains ouais et ça ça nous intéresse
moins parce qu'ils sont pas très connus
dont on a tant que petit copain dégage
est en général derrière voilà de plus
intéressant qui en général un peu connue
donc voilà c'est je voudrais encore de
la parole sur quelque chose je vous
promets qu'après c à vous sur aussi la
malédiction de la presse on se souvient
de vous ce vital man c'est c'est
mythique
on n'a pas à l'image qu'on n'a pas
d'argent on vous tend le micro et vous
dit où voyez vous dans dix ans et vous
répondez cette phrase très drôle à votre
place vous avez fait une très belle
carrière mais vous n'avez pas non plus
pris la place jean pierre foucault
tranche tf1 voilà est-ce que derrière il
n'y a pas cette malédiction aussi on va
toutes les miss qu'essaye de faire de la
télévision qui essaye d'exister
et puis bah comme elles sont jolies on
les met un peu en potiches à droite à
gauche
j'ai rien contre eric ménard mais à mon
avis dans un an cette jeune fille fall
fait un peu la météo et deux trois trucs
est là à me poser mais non mais c'est
vrai c'est vrai non moi j'ai besoin les
pleurs plusieurs années tf1 tf1 prend
d'en parler c'est une question de budget
derrière contre malheureusement ça
arrive à tout le monde quand on n'a plus
les moyens on arrête on passe à autre
chose
j'ai rebondi sur equidia pendant 11 ans
j'ai fait chroniqueuse dans différentes
après je suis devenue maman marié j'ai
trois enfants je fais plein de choses
dites et je vais de temps en temps quand
la télé mais je te fais défi je vais
spieser qui était là il ya quelques
semaines je l'âge après je vous dis la
vérité je l'a présenté jeudi miss france
2012 était avec nous qu'elle me dit
arrête de me présenter en tant que miss
france
je comprends que ce soit un problème et
en même temps ben pour l'instant été
miss france va tu as été miss france que
durant garde à vie autre chose fait
beaucoup plus d'années en tant
qu'animatrice télé qu'en tant que miss
france mais on considère encore comme
c'est vrai mais en même temps quand au
four sofa c'est vrai que dans l'ain cas
et dans l'autre et vous êtes formidables
et intelligente et je vous adore mais
c'est pas forcément en tant que ni
matrice de télé qu'on croit nous abriter
un plus
les magazines à l'élection l'a dit ici
c'est une chance pour magali berda qui
aura rêvé de faire ça je vais peut-être
le faire d'ailleurs
en fait non je trouve que c'est une
chance parce que ça vous ouvre aussi une
carrière maintenant par à votre époque
avait pas les réseaux sociaux
aujourd'hui à les réseaux sociaux et je
sais moi les miss france par exemple
elles deviennent de vrais influenceurs
donc d'ailleurs sylvie tellier elle a
ouvert une agence où elle vous bouquin
peu dès la sortie des miss manche c'est
vrai ou lll et 20 sur les réseaux
sociaux n'ont pas une entrée de bouc
énormément de miss france dans son
agence à contenait des déplacements
qu'elles ont une très belle image et ça
reste effectivement des filles populaire
shikata rachel et sophie donsey aux
filles on se connaît pas mais rachel on
sait comment c'est l'histoire entre elle
et moi da campine mathieu moi j'en ai
marre qu'on accuse les miss france et ce
concours de tous les maux du monde
n'importe qui qui va toucher la
notoriété aura forcément plus
d'opportunités amoureuse ça n'a rien à
voir avec un prime de miss ou pas la
deuxième chose c'est que est ce que
c'est une malédiction pas m'y attendais
le but de ce concours cdes et d'un
concours de beauté déjà qui apporte la
notoriété et ont déclaré la plus belle
femme de france
le reste c'est du bonus donc on va pas
spéculer en disant oui mais le bonus
n'est pas à la hauteur du concours c'est
du bonus
j'entends malédiction pour vous aimer
c'est une malédiction vasco si ce sont
des jeunes filles chez plus qui disait
ça c'était chloé mortaud ou pas on leur
fait miroiter tout un tas de choses
souvent elles arrêtent leurs études
parce qu'elles veulent voilà faire une
grande carrière finalement que dalle
donc oui ça peut être une malédiction y
en a peut-être 2 qui s'en sortent
vraiment alors peut-être que masse
grasse avec magali avons se faire un peu
de thunes grâce aux réseaux sociaux
mais jusqu'à présent il n'y a aucune
miss france qui a explosé a pas tort à
dormir et faites-les ne prenez pas pour
des débiles
enfin c'est pas vous n'êtes pas des
débiles à qui on dit ne voulait pas
croyez
orientaux qui aurait quelque chose et
l'audiovisuel non mais c'est sûr je
faisais des études audiovisuelles
c'était mon rêve mais il était ya vingt
ans après les faits elles ont voulu en
faire tout tout tout quand on leur tend
le micro max et je reprendrai mes études
de médecine de secrétariat de coiffure
et de machins y en a pas une qui liait
reprend tout derrière il y tiendra un
petit billet une caméra vous c'est ce
que s'est dit presque sûr qu'elle ne
reprenne pas ses vols
est-ce que c'est mal qu'elle ne reprenne
pas quand tu m'emmerdes intérêts la
jauge est offert dans la catéchèse la
catéchèse toute la télévision est non
alors qu'on n'est pas fonctionnaire
télévision de faire de la télévision pas
mis en a pas beaucoup qui ont une
carrière
énorme les 50 derniers remise à la télé
au cinéma ou au théâtre qui a explosé
c'est moi le bonheur absolu d'être connu
à la télévision pour vachon envie oui tu
m'as riegler phelim et qui est en train
de faire son internat je suis désolé
tout se passe bien pour juste un petit
mot pour vous dire quand même que les
trois les trois les trois les 3 et 3
les favorites mai de cette année c'est
miss tahiti miss rhône-alpes et miss
languedoc
voilà c'est passé d'accord ou pas on a
laissé des travaux rue de bitche tahiti
resort beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup
moi je suis pour miss ile-de-france faut
qu'on veut jamais pour rallier un anti
parisianisme à gaza les favoris depuis
surtout je sais des bookmakers manche où
les gens qui votent voilà c'est autre
chose me demander les amis vous restez
bien avec lou reed le sondage d'abord
malédiction ou concours de miss france
un champ si une malédiction est partagé
1 54% à 46 % en 2006 on se serait pas
après l'autre on se serait pas là on a
deux cas de chance vous êtes magnifique
et puis vous êtes sur ce plateau avec et
d'animateurs sellette
[Musique]
six d'entre eux mêmes et vous voyez on
passe notre temps à dire ah là là elles
sont dit mais elles sont débiles est ce
que vous les troupes pardon est ce qu on
voulait trouver des bills à samedi sont
saufs des dents mais on l'a fait de deux
super brillante savignac sans rire c'est
bien quand c'est fini c'est fini on en
reparlera